[موسيقى]
بدات تسوق العلاقه العلاقه بين وزاره
الدفاع
منذ الحادثه في دير الزور في سوريا عندما
قتل اكثر من 300 مقاتل ولم تعترف بهم
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه يعني اتصل
الامريكيون بوزاره الدفاع الروسيه وقال
لهم هل لديكم مقاتلين قرب
دير الزور قالت كلا اعادوا السؤال هل
لديكم مقاتلين قالوا فاتت
تعتبر مصدر في ذلك الوقت اكثر من 300
مقاتل من بدات على العلاقه تسوء
وصل الى مرحله متقدمه من الخلاف يعني لم
يعد يعجبه ما تريد وزاره الدفاع حتى انه
البارحه ضرب عله الحرب على اوكرانيا يعني
قال كانت اوكرانيا مستعده للتفاوض ولم يكن
هناك من سبب للذهاب الى هذه الحرب وكانه
ينتقد مباشره الرئيس بوتين خلال سير الحرب
وصلت المرحله الى انقطاع كامل بين وزاره
الدفاع
كان يحقق انتصارات وزاره الدفاع لم تلبيه
وبدات مرحله يعني التقليم الاظافر
لبريجوجين